Congress is back at work this morning
and Democrats are facing fallout from
sexual harassment claims against two
prominent lawmakers the longest serving
current members of Congress John Conyers
gave up his role as senior Democrat on
the House Judiciary Committee and
Senator Al Franken is talking at length
about the accusations for different
women
the Minnesota Democrat ended eight days
of silence by speaking to our
Minneapolis station WCCO he says he's
embarrassed and ashamed talk radio news
anchor Lee ant Whedon says Franken
forcibly kissed and groped her during a
USO tour in 2006 he apologized for photo
showing him touching her but says he
remembers the kissing incident
differently three other women say
Franken groped them while posing for
photos they Senate ethics committees
investigating the claims WCCO reporter
Esme Murphy is here this morning after
talking to Franken here is part of their
conversation have you ever placed a hand
on some woman's butt
you know III can't say that that hasn't
happened I take thousands and thousands
of pictures we sometimes in crowded in
chaotic situations I can't say I haven't
done that and I I'm I am very sorry if
these women experienced that and I have
to say that I have to be a lot more
sensitive a lot more a lot more careful
in these when I take a picture when I
meet someone and I'm going to make sure
that this does not happen again
can you really continue to claim kind of
a moral high ground on some of these
issues including the Trump Russian
investigation when a lot of people feel
you've been less than transparent about
these particular allegations well I I
think I I'm a good question and I think
that the questions that I'm asking don't
go to my Greta bility they go to the
credibility of the witness they go to
the credibility your credibility been
undermined I would say yeah
and I have a long way back I have a long
way back to win back the trust of the
people of Minnesota I've let people down
I've let the people of Minnesota down
I've let my friends and staff and
supporters down my family down
Esme Murphy is with us now good morning
good morning I know you've known the
senator for a long time as a prominent
Minnesota reporter how did you judge his
apology well I do think he was he is
genuinely anguished there's no question
about that I do think that there is a
problem here because he says he just
still does not remember these four
incidents these four separate claims
from these women and again I pressed him
on that I think if you grab somebody's
butt cheeks as one of the women
described it you're gonna remember it
did that surprise you that he said he
didn't remember well that's what he's
been saying but I think a lot of people
will look at him Gale as somebody this
is a very smart man and say how could
you not remember this is a man who
really prides himself on a lot of
details he insists he doesn't he says he
has a long way to go to regain the trust
of Minnesota voters and he will work
work very hard to do that what are they
saying in Minnesota about Senator
Franken you know what Gail I actually
thought about something that you said
last week in the aftermath of the
Charlie Rose allegations where you said
how do you wrap your head around it when
somebody you care about does something
that's bad and that for his supporters
for his supporters I think that's where
they're at right now there is a group of
65 prominent Democratic women who came
out yesterday and said they support him
that is a big deal and he said he has no
intention to resign he has absolutely no
intention to resign and what about the
allegations that he may have touched
someone's back during a picture having
been a political reporter I see many
times these politicians they pose for
thousands and thousands of pictures
right and there's a difference there's a
difference between having a hand around
somebody and grabbing their buttocks and
the statements were the three women who
are claiming that a remarkably similar
and that is a problem and he
acknowledged actually in that interview
that it's possible he could have done it
can you survive this yes or no do you
think you know I think at this point
especially with those 65 Democratic
women coming forward 14 staffers
including some that had very prominent
positions in his office are supporting
him 35 people from Saturday Night Live
women have signed a letter saying that
at this point yes if other things come
out though I think there's a problem all
right Esme Murphy thank you very much
thank you good morning absolutely nice
to have you at the table